but why is it the case Ben huh why is it
the case that you none of your
colleagues or you have been able to
offer one single condolence one single
condemnation one single word of sympathy
for any of the gazin that have been
killed don't try and smear us don't try
and slander us don't try and attack
don't try and produce red earrings and I
think you're an ass a jackass and we're
not talking about Hamas we're talking
about children here we're talking about
women here we're talking about elderly
people you make me sick your
reaction I mean everything that Muhammad
said to him and more uh complete
sick twisted human being